mark we've got you here MCM expert it's
great to have you here we wanted to talk
about mass effects what if in the most
memorable moments for you well if the
entire trilogy has been filled with
memorable moments from the perspective
of an actor doing it I guess it would be
getting a chance to meet Martin Sheen
that sort of thing getting to meet Seth
Green
I'd have to say also just the the
response from the fans getting to go to
conventions and meet fans I still
remember the first time that I saw
someone walk past me dressed as
Commander Shepard and that's what I knew
yes this is something special
now what about favorite death scenes as
well because there's some great ones in
there aren't there which ones a
particularly standout for you I'd have
to say probably Anderson's death scene
just that that scene in Mass Effect 3
that was a very emotional to record
actually it was it was a great scene and
it was real honored to get to do it with
Keith David about favorite lines as well
cuz he can be a little bit of a jerk
he's Sheppard he's had some good of
those lines as well
yeah I'd say all those renegade
interrupt lines and you know things like
I've got you know what was it I'll
relinquish one bullet where do you want
it things like that and of course you
know scheppers catchphrase I should go
we don't need to go yes has someone
questions
I read love that and what about favorite
romances in the series as well well that
mean there were all great romances when
I played let's see my paragon in the
first game romance Liara and then tally
in the second game and my renegade
romance - and then Miranda so I did not
show a lot of fidelity I'm sure it's
quite ladies man
yes yes or amazement depending he's
playing the game and we spoke to Allie
Hillis when she was here last year and
what was it like voicing those themes
with actors like Allie and Kimberly as
well I was amazing actually you know we
of course did not actually get to voice
them in the same room we had large cast
in many you know about three different
countries so it was hard to coordinate
schedules however we use a system called
Veda where you have the other actors
performance in your headsets as you're
recording your lines so that helps then
you're not acting into a vacuum so so
yeah it was it was fun to do those
scenes and you said that you'd like to
choose the renegade play through first
and then redeem yourself with the
Paragon play through but which of them
is your favorite and have you finished
the playthroughs for three years
I've not done my full playthroughs for
three just because I've been
so busy and of course there isn't the
added emphasis of like well I've got to
finish this playthrough before we start
recording the next game so I've got a
little more breathing room
and so I've procrastinated on my own my
playthroughs there I play favorites on
renegade or Paragon but I do have a
weakness for the renegade interrupts
I'll tend to use them even when I'm
playing Paragon because who doesn't want
to throw someone out a window really
don't mind oh yes yeah I have no
defenestration in real life now now have
you heard two Commander Shepard song on
YouTube I certainly have yeah the
miracle of sound one yes yes I have what
do you think of it oh I love it I love
it I love all this sort of fan stuff
that's sprung up around Mass Effect the
fan art the fan films I'm even in one
actually red sand which was produced by
the University of advancing technology
in Arizona and it was a class project
for the students in their digital video
program so they flew me down there and I
spent about three days and yeah it was a
the kids did a great job on it I was
really pleased with the way it turned
out I don't actually play commander
shepard in that i it's at 40 years
before the first game so it's a bit of a
prequel and deals with the discovery of
the Prothean technology on mars and I
play a character of the books actually
John Grissom I like it a nice change of
definitely now what do you think we
might expect to see in the Mass Effect
universe in the future well really they
could go anywhere I've been speaking
about it before that it's such a fully
realized fictional universe that you
know there's infinite possibilities you
could go ahead in time you could go back
you could see the first contact war with
the humans and the turians mele the
sky's the limit and if I didn't know
which direction that we're going I
couldn't tell you but as a van I can
speculate so we like to know where you
might like it to go to now what about
this Mass Effect maybe that's what we
all want to know about yeah well you
know what I don't you know I'm hoping
now I'll get to do a little cameo as a
Silurian or something that's it that's I
don't think I played commander shepard
i'm more slim like slurring who would
you like to see in that role and if you
could choose anybody well you know I'm
friends with Nathan Fillion so I tend to
recommend him for these sort of roles I
think I think that he would you know
fans would love to see him in that role
also his serenity and Firefly castmate
Adam Baldwin would be a good choice in
he's got
look I'm liking both those choices I
like to see that go ahead and what about
director as well any thoughts for that
would be interesting
James Gunn might be an interesting
choice actually and I know that Nathan's
worked with him of course on slither
I've enjoyed all his films super as well
and and I write and you know he is
actually doing a space film coming up
because I think he's going to be doing
guardians of the galaxy actually how'd
you keep your voice consistent when you
doing voice I think of something like
Mass Effect
well one thing is that they they tend to
limit sessions to about four hours so
that our voice doesn't get too tired so
that you can sound the same at the
beginning of the session and as at the
end we also attended to save sort of
strenuous scenes for the end of the
session and particularly in my case we
do all the vorcha and the alien voices
at the end of a given session so shepard
was always sort of kept as fresh as
possible and if you anything you'd like
to say to fans out there who are
watching this interview with you
I should go well we're sorry to hear
that but we love speaking to you thanks
so much mark thank you very much thanks
revenue
you